an ammunitions depot has exploded in
crimea a week after similar blasts
rocked a russian air base on the annex
peninsula the russian defense ministry
originally attributed the blasts to a
fire at a military warehouse but now
says the damage is the result of
sabotage local officials say two people
were injured while another 2 000 were
evacuated as a precaution
ukraine has neither confirmed nor denied
its involvement in the recent blasts in
crimea the peninsula was illegally
annexed by russia in 2014.
dw correspondent down phillip schultz is
in keefe this isn't the first such blast
in crimea what has kiev been saying
about these incidents
of course hardly anybody here
believes that it's just a strange series
of accidents and some ukrainian
officials have made comments that leave
some room for interpretation let's say
shortly after the explosions
presidential advisor tweeted that
invaders have to understand that there
is a high risk of death in occupied
territories for them
so hardly
anybody believes
in an accident and
for many ukrainians
crimea is one of the
most symbolic places of this war they
would welcome any possible attack on
russian facilities there as you know
crimea has been occupied by russia for
the past eight years and president
zelinski has repeatedly made it clear
that any efforts to win the war any
effort to take back occupied territory
must include crimea
concerns are also growing about the
strikes near the safaris nuclear plant
what's the latest there
yes local authorities say that artillery
attacks have continued very close to the
plant in the past 48 hours that is very
concerning and they
say
that the russian side says that the
ukrainians are responsible for the
attacks and vice versa they blame
each other as usual
but we were able to talk to some
engineers that worked
at the plant until recently and they
confirm that the situation is getting
increasingly alarming a lot of
facilities have been destroyed in recent
days in theory both ukraine and russia
agree that there should be
a mission of international inspectors
but they disagree on the conditions
russia rejects any mission that travels
through uh non-occupied ukrainian uh
territory so at the moment there
is a little uh sign for improvements uh
unfortunately that is unfortunate young
philip schultz thank you very much for
bringing us up to date
on the situation in ukraine